oh okay how do I even [ __ ] start
you know Monday happy Monday everybody
and to say my weekend was amazing it
would be [ __ ] putting it mildly
Wow what up what a [ __ ] weekend and
rock actually all the [ __ ] that's going
on you know Saturday it was like noon I
decided to go out to Coachella I didn't
decide then I was going but I mean
that's what time I decided to leave I
didn't really need to see anybody at
Coachella except ice cube and Guns and
Roses there was a lot of great bands
playing I'm not slagging I'm just saying
like a lot of those bands I'd rather
just see in smaller venues so I'll wait
for them to come around and do like
troubadour and palladium and and stuff
like that which oh by the way how is
everybody today sorry I'm just [ __ ]
I'm still jacked from the weekend I'm
just like floating around my apartment
like what the [ __ ] did I just see ya got
on the motorcycle at the harley-davidson
and rode out solo I always go to
Coachella solo I I think that a couple
things I've learned over my life first
of all it's cool to go to things alone
just [ __ ] once in a while you know
get inside your head I go to the movies
alone all the time I think it's one of
the only ways to go because you never
know what your [ __ ] buddies movie
etiquette is you know there's a lot of
guys that text during the movies I just
write them off I don't go to the movies
to them or those dudes that just move
about in their seat make noise why they
[ __ ] eat and their [ __ ] whatever yeah
I'm a weirdo I like to go play solo and
I find I find this happens when you go
solo for me at least over the hundred
years of seeing concerts
if your solo and something special could
happen it's gonna happen because your
solo meaning like oh hey you want to go
backstage or hey do you want to be in
the front row or hey I got an extra
ticket that gets you over here whatever
whenever you're with someone they go oh
but your buddy can't go and then it's
that weird thing of like [ __ ] I love my
buddy but oh [ __ ] a minute
my point is once in a while go somewhere
alone get in your own head go go [ __ ]
don't go camping alone don't do that
that's creepy and weird but I'm saying
road trips stuff like that I've done
many many road trips alone on the
motorcycle and it's just been epic find
out who the [ __ ] you are so I ride out
to Coachella beautiful weather this
weekend in LA after the shitty windstorm
we had we had the worst [ __ ]
windstorm [ __ ] wind nobody likes the
wind I've never heard anybody go you
know what man I wish it was just a nice
windy day nice and windy don't go
together
ever ever wind sucks wind sucks it's
it's only good for getting us some power
some of those those power fans that's it
the wind is the worst I remember I was
with burns and in Wyoming Cheyenne
Wyoming and there's nothing out there so
it's just [ __ ] wind the entire time
and it just stopped me in my tracks I
was like how is it so [ __ ] windy out
here burrows like they got no buildings
nothing blocking anything it's just I
mean if we didn't have any [ __ ]
buildings or just me the whole earth
would be a windstorm [ __ ] you wind I
hope you're tuning in oh man I feel good
today so I ride out and it's a great
[ __ ] day 80 degrees and over the
years of course I've gone to all the
Coachella as I believe it set
one so over the years I have a very very
close friend who was involved with
Coachella since the day one he's been my
friend for like probably thirty years
now and hooks it up man
hooks it up beyond beyond the way I go
to Coachella it's and it's not bragging
but I couldn't go any other way once you
it's like it's like if you I don't even
know how to explain it
it's like if you've ever been in a
private jet or or a [ __ ] limousine or
something I don't even know what the
[ __ ] I'm saying but what I'm saying is I
get out there I park and I've got the
the golden ticket the incredible
wristband that gets you backstage and
get myself a cup of waters I'm about two
hours early before Ice Cube I'm there to
see Ice Cube who's on at 9:00 and then
G&R 10:30 which right away when you look
at that you go how is that even possible
you know ice cubes playing from 9:00 to
10:00 and then G and I are on at 10:30
I'm like yeah and so I'm really watching
out I drank a shitload of waters but
I'll sand I'm like oh that's a bad move
because once the band starts I don't
want to have to go piss anyway I sit
around for a couple of hours just
relaxing taking it in and who's the
first [ __ ] guy see backstage when I'm
walking in Joe Walsh right away I go
well this [ __ ] day's gonna be great
go up shake his hand I'm like Jill wells
which by the way Jill Walsh and it's
very well-documented has done armies of
drugs and looks [ __ ] great
some people man I mean you know I think
the more drugs they did the better they
look it's crazy
of course it's Queen now but what I'm
saying is
some people do drugs and they just look
Haggard as [ __ ]
I guess it's did Joe Walsh and that
Eagles money just like you know you just
get pampered because this guy look
[ __ ] dynamite he's like 20 years
older than me and he looked way better
than me and he's such a great guy
I love him of course played some gigs
for the music artistic awesome human and
one of the most underrated rock bands of
all time James Gang and of course he
just smokes it in the Eagles just a god
he's backstage I guess he played with
someone cuz he had a guitar I missed it
unfortunately I don't know what he did
I'm gonna have to google it but he had
his guitar case and he was walking out
and I was like [ __ ] Joe Walsh what a
what an epic sighting that was so then I
start making my way into the VIP area to
watch Ice Cube who comes on and opens up
with one of my favorite ice cube songs
which is funny because Ice Cube put a
record out about five years ago and had
a song on there called gangster rap made
us - made me do it I don't think a lot
of people heard it of course it's the
standard of most music fans they stopped
buying or lose interest in anything they
like after a to three year period unless
they're a super fan like myself from
probably most of you that tune into this
podcast I followed bands careers all the
way through some I outgrow some bands I
outgrow yeah you're just like yeah it's
not really my thing anymore but I still
will check out what they're doing cube
had a record out and they had this song
gangster rap made me do it he opens with
it comes up to story stage with a
[ __ ] throne that's shaped like the
West Side hand signal rocking it up
there gangster rap made me do it
I love cube I've always loved cube he's
he's been absolutely him NWA Public
Enemy
Tupac those are the rappers to me the
dangerous the ones with incredible
lyrics and messages and just next-level
[ __ ] from back in the day I never never
miss cube when he comes around I try to
see him I've seen him many times all the
way back to the wicked CD at the
Warfield that was fire used to wear the
wicked shirt everywhere I went huh I
love NWA about the movie I love
everything about Ice Cube the guy is
smoked and he crushed it in boys in the
hood one of my favorite films he also
killed it on three kings and i did a
movie with him called the longshots if
you didn't know that and I got to spend
about two months with him out in
Shreveport and I just love that man and
he's a full-blown full-blown winner
I mean records that kill movies that
kill the guy made it still making it
just got into the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame and I loved what Cube said about
what rock and roll is clowning on gene
Simmons I agree with it at the time that
NWA was out I say there's there was
nothing more metal or rock than NWA at
the time it was the next wave of metal
to me and Debbie a to me is metal it's
it's just so aggressive and powerful and
it [ __ ] with your emotions and they
deserve it they deserve to be in the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame I believe
that for sure there's no rap Hall of
Fame or soul Hall of Fame or [ __ ] yeah
there's country of but you know what I
mean
they were [ __ ] there they crossed
genres you know like Axl Warren NWA hat
rockers worshipped NWA every party I
went to it'd be like myth
Chanukah record undoing onto an NWA
record onto a [ __ ] you know
Parliament record Funkadelic whatever no
rules no rules man
sunny way he rocks it in mid-set poop
brings out MC Ren and and yella and they
do some [ __ ] nwa [ __ ] the police and
straight out of Compton that Snoop Dogg
[ __ ] comes out I mean this is like
the holy grail of West Coast rap Snoop
Dogg killin it
which by the way when Snoop Dogg came
out the entire Coachella went ballistic
that guy is still a monster star I mean
a monster star what a [ __ ] winner
snoop dogg snoop lion snoop lion
Maroni's snoop lion that was hilarious I
love when people go crazy that'd be
funny if I just changed my name I'm
gonna be Yoda this year I'm just gonna
be Yoda changing my name to Yoda del Rey
anyway then they they do a killer hour
set ten o'clock exactly off and and and
cube had an elaborate stage he had like
a two-story thing with [ __ ] you know
it took a while to put together but
these guys tore that thing apart in
about ten minutes and started wheeling
out the Guns and Roses equipment and and
I swear to give and and and this goes
out to all the people all the people and
I can tell the message that Axl Senden
it's a it's a huge [ __ ] you to whatever
you're gonna say on Twitter or whatever
he walked on stage at 10:30 at ten
[ __ ] thirty bullseye dead-on time and
and by the way I can't tell people this
enough but I had seen Guns and Roses
for the last and I think I talked about
this on the G in our podcast last week
I've seen him over the last five years
and the going on stage late was long
over that was years ago years ago no one
ever talks about the good stuff you know
like it was long over maybe he'd be
20-30 min uh past the time there on but
there boom they were on it was never
like like the old days of four or five
hours but I tell you what ad Coachella
Saturday night they [ __ ] walked on at
10:30 and destroyed the desert it's so
easy into well is it mr. brownstone I
mean [ __ ] once again destroyed and I
I I'm leaving out a little factor during
right when they come on my buddy sees me
and goes oh you're going in the photo
pit where I'm up there with only four
people three feet away from the [ __ ]
band so me thinking bummed I didn't see
the Troubadour gig this was way cooler
three feet away in front of 80,000
people I'm in front of 80,000 people I
turn around I see what the Guns & Roses
band is seen the view of sea of [ __ ]
rockers and and and and by the way don't
be delusional people hit me on Twitter
like these guys are gonna bring rock
back this is this is the this is the
next coming and all that no no no you
know I'm not [ __ ] dumb that was a
different era when people bought records
and and and people went out and saw
bands at a low low level and followed
them all the way through their career
till they got huge if they got huge and
if they didn't get huge people didn't
care that was their band that's a
different era that's I don't see that
ever happening again that's no computer
error that
it's no cellphone era that's ten TV
stations 12 TV stations at the most with
the [ __ ] knob you turned or the early
remote control with the clicker 12 TV
stations a couple local radio stations
once again no cell phones no computers
nothing you had some books you had some
records and you had [ __ ] you know a
bicycle to ride around and that sounds
like some old caveman [ __ ] but that's
how people became obsessed with stuff
they loved because they were like this
is what I got and that's how I became
obsessed with music of course and Guns
and Roses like I've said over and over
favorite band on the planet one of them
absolutely it's three it's like ac/dc
metallica Guns and Roses what happens
boom Angus Young [ __ ] comes out on
stage there's two of my favorite combo I
[ __ ] got goosebumps right now telling
you this story
he comes out full [ __ ] outfit a light
blue angus outfit I've never seen it
almost looked like it was one of his
ghetto ones like just give me the ghetto
Angus suit he comes out Axel's like we
got a special guest and by the way four
hours before that they had announced
that axel will be doing the ten gigs
with guns and wrote over the ACDC
which which I started thinking all
[ __ ] planets are aligning for for Axl
this guy has been drugged through the
dirt for 15 years people saying this
that whatever and I'm not some [ __ ]
Rock buffoon but what I'm saying is that
guy carried the torch he carried the
torch and and and they always say hard
work pays off and look here at the end
everything is Axl Rose right now 2016
who would have thought that who would
have thought crazy he comes [ __ ]
rolling out Angus they break into a
whole lot of Rosie which was [ __ ]
great
Axl just killing it and then I thought
okay that was cool I didn't I didn't
think yeah I thought one song at this
mid set to about three-quarters in it's
not the on course but they says hey you
want another one
and they do riff raff which I haven't
heard live in a hundred years and that's
when I knew oh [ __ ] I need to see ac/dc
with Axl now here's my thoughts on it of
course I got thousands of tweets people
all right what are you gonna say about
it
and yes I am [ __ ] destroyed Brian's
out it's it's still crazy to me to me
this almost feels like sports I'm not a
big sports guy I was growing up I love
sports I do love the San Francisco
Giants
I love the 49ers and I love Golden State
Warriors I love watching that [ __ ]
it's exciting you know but I'm not like
obsessed with it like I am with music
and I understand if you are that's cool
everybody needs their thing but what
this feels like to me is almost like
sports your favorite guy got traded to
another team because your other guy got
injured or whatever so they got a new
quarterback and in in and with with
sports I see a lot of people they're
like oh [ __ ] him he went to
such-and-such team sports is 100% money
if you don't think it is you're out of
your mind
I
never understood people that like beat
up people in the crowd that were wearing
the opposite teams logos like that guy
that got [ __ ] you know you know
almost killed at the Dodger parking lot
I never have stood that step because
I'll tell you one thing right now those
players don't give a [ __ ] about you as
fans they don't give a [ __ ] about you
all they care about is making a giant
check and playing in the NFL or or you
know the MLB or the NBA whatever they
don't care who the fans are you know and
unless it's an old-school world of
sports I'm talking about the new world
the old school where guys played on a
team their whole career and they were
like I want to I want to thank all the
fans and all that or their personal fans
when a quarterback bounces around a few
teams they've got fans Joe Montana [ __ ]
yeah he's got fans you know Steve Young
yeah he's got fans Jerry Rice those are
legacy players from a legacy team and I
get that but what is really weird to me
and hard to stomach because you don't
see it is band members going to
different bands Velvet Revolver was a
lot a lot like like that you know they
were basically G&R with a different
singer no one ever talked about that you
know what I mean
that was GNR with a different singer the
lineup right there you know with Scout
Scott singing and that was a hybrid
there's a lot of hybrid stuff over the
years most of it doesn't work once in a
while it does work Audioslave another
thing that's Rage Against the Machine
with a different [ __ ] singer that
that is that's three guys you're used to
seeing a play in different different
music with a new singer there's uh you
know it's rare that you see it and and
here it is it's gonna happen with Axl
and it's funny if you if you listen to
my episode I don't know which one it was
but the day Brian was out I was doing a
bitching with Spicer and I said Who I
mean who are they gonna get I mean maybe
they get Axl that would be [ __ ] cool
I said it on that day just thinking in
my mind wow that would be crazy because
of course there's two guys I [ __ ]
love axon Angus
but I just threw it out there and now
it's [ __ ] happening I'm like well how
am I gonna see that at the garden I need
to see that now this statement the
issued statement is we are thankful that
Axl will fill in for these ten shows now
so everybody this I'm saying this
because everybody's asking me what do
you think of him replacing it no where
does it say he joined he's a member
he's just filling in for the last ten
shows now if that's really what they're
doing for the last ten shows I got no
problem with that
I got no problem with that at all maybe
they have Brian come down or something
for a couple tunes who knows but the
problem now I would have is if Axl does
ten and then doesn't do any more then
they get another guy or a different star
or whatever that goes back to burning
your legacy now what I want to say right
here and this is what I'm gonna say
about it and probably it won't be the
last time because people ask me over and
over the
two of my favorite bands but what I
truly believe and I saw it on Saturday
night at Coachella when when Angus came
out and played with Guns & Roses I
realized right there what I've been
saying for the last month and a half or
whatever Axl or Angus Young and friends
would work
people loved Angus and to keep loving
him he should not [ __ ] do the wrong
move
retire the ac/dc brand get dudes whoever
it is you're you can use the ac/dc guys
but go out as Angus Young and friends
you don't need to play [ __ ] arenas
play theatres play deep tracks because
when Angus and Axl did riff raff I lost
my [ __ ] mind to hear some deep tracks
as Angus Young and friends it would be
epic and I mean [ __ ] epic and it
would keep the legacy clean and it would
keep the [ __ ] brand iconic and and it
would be super [ __ ] cool to see and
it would easily be able to go another
eight years which would put Angus about
70 years old and probably you know
probably at the way he moves and plays
would probably be close to the end
unless he just stood in one spot because
he is a [ __ ] monster player and and I
would even watch him just standing in
one spot in street clothes I'm almost at
that point to where I love Angus so much
I would see him in any kind of situation
outside of ac/dc
that
it's exciting to me you know even like
acoustic Angus would be crazy never seen
it anyway that is my full heartfelt
feeling on this after seeing him on
Saturday I truly believe that he could
do Angus Young and friends and look like
a [ __ ] hero and have dream scenarios
for the next eight years Angus and some
guys and different singers you know who
wouldn't want to see that everyone and I
also believe that after the 10 shows
they should do some kind of monster
residency somewhere maybe the garden
maybe maybe the forum somewhere epic and
do like a 5 day goodbye with Brian give
this guy the [ __ ] proper love he has
been there since day one when you when
you needed a singer he's on the biggest
record of all time back in black this
guy is not some [ __ ] slouch and I've
said it over and over give this man the
proper love he deserves it he deserves
it and it would be smoking hot say
goodbye to everyone go out with Angus
Young and friends and boom everybody's
[ __ ] happy that's my thoughts on that
one last thing before I get into the
episode which today my episode is my
great friend speak in Iraq no better
guest to have today than jim Florentine
from that metal show
also comedian of course everyone knows
him and great friend of mine what a what
a cool human
before I bring them on though one last
thing the rumblings of this concert
that's gonna go down in October out from
the from the Coachella people is I'm
calling it Mount rocks more they mount
rocks more you got the who Roger Waters
Rolling Stones Neil Young Bob Dylan I
mean come on what the [ __ ] a three-day
event I think there's someone else - am
I missing one I mean come on man
the who Roger Waters Neil Young Rolling
Stones Bob Dylan that is a must [ __ ]
see I'm going to the desert that weekend
and I am not leaving for three days and
if some of you might think that sounds
like a bunch of [ __ ] grandpas and
[ __ ] just be known that this will be one
of those shows that people talk about 20
years from now like when these guys are
gone when these guys are gone they're
gonna be like remember that [ __ ]
mount rocks more hashtag that mount
rocks more [ __ ] man
Dylan stones a fired-up Neil Young man
Roger Waters [ __ ] I saw him twice in the
last five years the guy murders the who
Psalm first time 82 their first farewell
tour the clash opened [ __ ] alright I
love all you guys and the amount of
tweets and emails I got from that Guns
and Roses episode last week absolutely
blew my mind I felt so [ __ ] good and
I can't thank you guys enough for tuning
in the show's getting bigger and bigger
and and it just feels so [ __ ] good
hard work paying off you guys are all
coming out to the comedy shows
III headline Irvine last week almost 200
people there that that [ __ ] it blows my
mind
Irvine is huge holds like 600 but 200 on
a Wednesday night that's that's [ __ ]
means a lot to me
people are getting out a Wednesday I
know most people don't want to go out on
Wednesday unless you live in a big city
like Hollywood or [ __ ] in New York
Middle America they don't want to go out
they got to work they got kids they got
[ __ ] headaches and bills I get it so
thank you red band and bartnik they're
[ __ ] great night man unbelievable so
thank you I'll be at the La Jolla Comedy
Store this weekend Friday and Saturday
with my boy Spicer
come see us I'll be headlining there
it's gonna be so [ __ ] fun San Diego
show up let's party for shows this
weekend and Wednesday night I'm doing
the iconic meltdown show on 4/20
meltdown show right here in Hollywood
the biggest show in America the biggest
comedy show meltdown
Jonah ray love you buddy all right keep
leaving the reviews we're at what do we
have 550 I think I think we have 550 on
iTunes leave those reviews if everyone
left a review if this show would go in
the top five I guarantee it
I got so many listeners if everyone left
a review today after you listen to the
episode if everyone left a review this
show would be in the top five in stoy
that's how it [ __ ] works takes five
minutes takes one minute one minute boom
five star show candles lit and you're
out of there so [ __ ] cool man I'm
still jacked still jacked on that
[ __ ]
he can insane let's get into the episode
thank you guys here he is jim Florentine
all right what's happened in another
episode I'll have to be talked out a
great old friend of mine
jim Florentine here in LA for a week
we're gonna go see Guns & Roses I can't
wait for that man right yeah you see
they got a girl on keyboards yeah yeah
yeah our buddy Scottie saw em yeah yes
got it ed said it was amazing the show
last week at the troubadour I was in
line with him and I got clowned oh you
did I was the worst that was about a
hundred people behind him and it's so
bummer because the promises came up to
me and she goes you're good they're
gonna release actually three hundred
tickets it was supposed to be 250 but by
the touch Scottie went in it was number
18 and then there's probably a hundred
people when it all said they said all
the tickets are gone sorry so I think
what happened was they band made a call
and said hey we need more guests or so
lowly
yeah because all the Sooners that word
got out all the celebrities and
everybody and you know totally closed
people that a band wanted to come so I'm
sure that's what happened
yeah it was crazy uh I got up at 8:00
rode the motorcycle over the hill stood
in the Sun it was blaze and man I mean
hot my and yeah I wasn't even thinking
that you know when I get the text I just
throw on my clothes and ride over and
then I might go [ __ ] the sun's out how
long when you're online before three
hours three hours where you realize you
weren't gonna take it yeah and it was a
bummer because the lady actually I was
with a guy from he was a writer for LA
Times or something she came right up and
she said you guys are good don't worry I
just kind of counted it off you're about
a hundred and eighty or good and so we
were like fired up I was texting people
like I'm going I didn't go well Scottie
said he got there the night before
yeah yeah just said just you know so
yeah well I'm excited this weekend cuz
I'm sure they're gonna do a longer show
and they did there yeah and there's a
lot of covers in that set yeah yeah only
two songs off illusion
I mean really like well a devil talking
jive and you could be mine but I mean
I'm not counting the covers of like Live
and Let Die
you know but man not much tunes from
those records yeah that was probably
just a short condensed yes I'm sure
they're gonna do like two and a half
hours yeah I can't wait yeah I know how
some chains open I know it's gonna be
it's gonna be amazing
can be a great weekend it's funny too
because they sounded great you watch it
I saw some clips yeah yeah yeah like Axl
sounded good man he's you know I always
stick up for him he gets a bad rap some
moments where he didn't sound so good
you know it was a picture online of him
being overweight yeah okay so everybody
puts a few pounds on here and yeah and
then they take it off and then they put
it on they take it off when he's not on
tour yeah so what so what you know he's
not in the gym working out and stuff
like that when he knows he's got a tour
to go he gets in shape just like every
actor does and yeah every football
player and all a lot of stuff so he gets
a bad rap you know what the thing is
with him is he doesn't defend himself
yeah you know he just says look or
whatever they people say I'm not gonna
answer to everything cuz it's so crazy
what they say about me he just keeps
quiet so everyone just keeps piling on
yeah yeah man I mean I you know I give
mad props he's been rolling the whole
time you know like I mean of course he
disappeared for years to do the Chinese
Democracy but I've been seeing him since
the first run at the Hard Rock New
Year's Eve years ago with yeah bucket
head and all that yeah I mean see I've
been seeing him you know steadily since
like 2004 yep 2005 maybe and his version
is so good I mean that diversion of Guns
Rose that he had was there was they were
doing three hour shows yeah I know and
it was great the shows were great too I
never understood that they're like oh I
heard he sounds like [ __ ] I'm like no
man he sounds amazing sounded running
around like a maniac he's got a great
band you know so but whatever that's
what people thing with Van Halen what
Rauf they were like all I heard he sucks
you know I saw my Jimmy Kimmel it sound
so uh so what you know what it means
but you know and then you go see if
people will see oh my god that show was
amazing yeah they opened up with the
light up the sky yeah yeah okay exactly
just go to stop listening to one guy
it's well also you add some volume and
your excitement in there and you're like
I'm at the [ __ ] show yeah I know I
mean what else you gonna do sit home and
say that sucks already' go out
absolutely you're gonna pay 130 bucks
for [ __ ] dinner with your wife yeah
and a bottle of wine so you mourn should
go see van Halen they come around every
four years yeah they're not gotta go see
them for that price Oh tickets are too
expensive they're not
I would pay just to go see Eddie play
you know if you get the other guys
that's a bonus and Eddie was murdering
it this last round
oh right man I tell you I just saw man
David Gilmour who Floyd man he was
crushing it was good yeah I'll talk
about a guitar god you know just
underrated you know absolutely the guy
man is just like the king like he just
played that thing he's like I don't know
70 or something he just played like it
was nothing
you know so good Wow yeah what are you
up to man so you're out in LA you're
pumping up this special you got out I
got it right here DVD I'm your Savior
now you film this and then it never came
out and you decided to put out yourself
right uh you know what it was a one-man
show I started doing like four years ago
right I did it probably like 20 times
and then I put it on the shelf about two
years ago I wasn't sure I was gonna deal
with it and I just started working on
some other stuff I got busy with some
other stuff and then it's just been
sitting there I'm like I might as well
put it out yep mmm so you know it's a
slide show - it's basically the story of
my life start when I was a kid through
whatever grown up you know strict
Catholic altar boy you know have you
know Jersey Jersey yeah you know
socially awkward no girlfriends you know
in the Pro Wrestling and heavy metal
yeah if you're into pro wrestling and
having metal growing up as a kid you
don't have you don't you're not in the
girls it's so funny that whole pro
wrestling thing fully missed me like I
didn't even dig it at all I was so into
rock but I'd never was sat down and it
was like wrestling all those guys at the
store loved it you know and I'm just
kind of like I don't I don't get it you
know what probably from age like 10 to
14 yeah is when I real what I was really
into or 10 maybe he's maybe 15 or
something like that
I got into that and then once I realized
it was fake it took me to I was 15 years
old to realize it was fake then I got
pissed I'm like I'm not watching this
[ __ ] anymore I totally got another medal
I remember a few like I don't know maybe
7 years ago a buddy of mine called and
said hey Shane McMahon's in town and he
he wants to go riding with someone you
want to go riding with him I don't
really have time and I was like yeah
I'll do it
Shane McMahon he's yeah his dad owns
that [ __ ] wrestling and everything so
we went riding and hung out for the day
and then he invited me to the show and I
drops [ __ ] front row and I was so
funny in front row is like how [ __ ]
fake is that I mean it's so fake front
row you know and I remember that whole
thing back in the day with Geraldo where
he's like it's fake and they [ __ ]
smacked him one you know yeah yeah pack
them in the face was a lawsuit and all
that and uh yeah I don't know I just for
some reason I got into it as a kid and
uh you know I show all these pictures
this guy basically molested me for
wrestling pictures Wow and I tell the
whole story in my one-man show
he was the rest of at Agra so you have
these great pictures it's almost like a
rock guy yeah yeah and he be outside of
Madison Square Garden every month there
was a wrestling match and I go my dad or
my brothers whatever and he'd be out
there because he was in front row taking
the pictures and we buy him off for a
buck apiece yeah and then he started
becoming friendly with us cuz we don't
we go see him in that same spot and he
was and then eventually we went down
through Asbury Park a convention hall to
see wrestling when our parents let us go
by ourselves take a train down there and
he has front row yeah I went up sitting
on his lap whoa well cuz we were up in
the nosebleeds yeah right it tells me
goes hey he comes up there in between a
match he goes look I got two open seats
in the front there was like five of us
because any want to come down and me my
friend Michael will go can we get down
to the front rotors only one seed oh I'm
like where's the other see now I should
have known better I'm 14 years old like
I was seven Wow
and he's like I goes ones mine I go
where Mike were see so where how we
gonna sit he goes well someone's going
to sit on my lap whoa like I'm not
sitting on your lap my friend might grab
the other seat I'm lying I'm arguing
with him all of a sudden I see Andre the
Giant coming on a dress come they're
like oh my holy [ __ ] I'm 14 years old
I'm like nine feet away from Andre oh my
god [ __ ] it I'll take your boner for
Andre yes I sound that's laugh
and watts imagine any yeah yeah no
halfway through he nibbled on my ear
whoa yeah and then I realized all right
this guy's a [ __ ] creep
whoa man what do you think having that
guy ever Facebook him no he's on I asked
him having my one-man show I got a
picture on the sex offenders list hmm
there's a picture of them on there and
he's living in Thailand now whoa he
molested like twenty kids we found out
like other kids and stuff like that but
you know that was a day when you know
early 80s late 70s when I was a where
you know you the parents trusted priest
yeah oh yeah go go camping with him for
the weekend he's an adult he's a father
figure you know go hang out Cub Scout
dudes kamikaze all of that stuff so
wrestling guy was no different
Wow you know so uh but then out it
didn't end just there cuz then I got man
he would give me a picture and not to
say anything and then next time I see
him he's like if you give me kissing the
cheek I'll give you this I never you
know Hulk all been really glad in the
beginning yeah but I and I show up I
still have the pictures I saved all the
pictures I show them in the slideshow
yeah in in the special wow thing yeah
yeah I understand all the pictures from
back when it got it from me and then uh
the whole thing where you know you tell
I don't want to give away the whole
story but it's creepy but I try to make
it funny and showing the pictures Wow
wow that's heavy [ __ ] I always wanted to
do a one-man show and how do you how do
you do it because it seems like it's a
lot of [ __ ] work right it took me two
years to write it right yeah and it's
just you know and then performed in
front of like five seven people like I
would do this local comedy club even
though it's not a comedy club piece on
like a Wednesday night in front of like
seven nine people whatever it was and
just just work it out and record a tape
it listen back to it and stuff because
it's more storytelling so it's not that
setup punch set up punch right of course
you know so it was tough to do it really
was but I tell the whole running theme
throughout is how I was always addicted
to troubled women yeah and it's always
end in a disaster and I got it for my
mom because my mom was young over there
was seven of us she raised you know my
my parents married 33 years but she
would just take people in off the street
she was like Mother Teresa
oh yeah anyone if she felt bad yes that
Florentine kalapa yeah [ __ ] yeah
homeless guy VA having dinner
you notice anyone that was sick in the
neighborhood couldn't afford a carrier
so I always that's what that's the women
I picked what's the disasters that need
to be taken care of
yeah you know Michael I I can make let
me bring her in and oh you know I could
fix her make her better
you dated Robin from Howard's Howard she
was she no that's that's the exception I
was probably my best relationship I've
ever had it wasn't didn't last long
yeah because you didn't know how to deal
with robbery yeah Robbie it was like man
this is too uh that was more of a
schedule thing where we just our
schedules right I remember you telling
me that but I was just wondering if she
was that wasn't more of like you know
we're both in between relationships we
both got a long relationships and stuff
and we just you know start a hanging and
stuff it Altima didn't work out but that
was a great one yeah you know looking
back well in the one-man show I tell
about an ex-girlfriend that I that I
dated and I felt bad for I took her in
she ultimately committed suicide oh I
tell that whole story about the night I
found there I was up on stage and came
back and found her in my apartment and
then it basically you know after a
couple years to recover
she basically led me to my future wife
Wow so it ends on a nice thing where I
got a wife now in a kid it was because
of my axe in a weird way she's but
meanwhile that blow up so that's that's
gonna be part sail away are you damaged
goods now you think four women are you
just like no more like relationships you
think no that's well it's pretty brutal
the one before was even broke you know
Wow suicide yeah even worse I would say
so dinner divorce well I know but I mean
of course you're bummed you lose someone
she kills herself but that's something
you really can't you can't foresee could
you like what's she like I'm gonna kill
myself oh you know she had depression
issues you know she had a lot of issues
from her childhood and stuff like that
and uh you know adopted and all I know
you know yeah so but I always just
thought it was she was gonna be okay
don't worry I'm gonna take care you know
it's gonna be fine yeah you know and
this is line in there where I you know I
basically you know I think I could save
her so I'm like that's what I call it
I'm your Savior I'm like don't worry I'm
you know yeah so um I went up afterwards
I went up going and it's like this
spiritual healer like a medicine man oh
you
yeah and in Jersey no out here I flew
out to LA to see ya oh of course I was
gonna say that [ __ ] don't exist in
Jersey yeah yes so I come out here and I
basically like he's helping me through
it I'm tell him the whole story is
helping me throwing him like I thought I
could save her and he's like first of
all he goes he goes you're not God it
goes because you're not saving anybody
cuz you wearing a Judas Priest shirt who
you think you can say that's a line in
there you know yeah I did I think I had
the British steel shirt on yeah yeah
yeah yeah I just think it's Cinderella
the whole time somebody say yeah was she
a rocker oh yeah yeah I love Manson
where'd you guys meet oh of course
see there's your there's your red flag
right right yeah man you know Manson
Type O Negative was she a stripper she
like no she wasn't but I know it sounds
like yeah yeah type on that could have
Manson but that she also like Slipknot
and oh yeah yeah she liked all but she
liked the dance music - right a little
bit of both but I know herself in your
house yeah my apartment Wow yeah in
Jersey or New York New Jersey wow I was
opening for dice onstage at a theater
Wow he come home yeah Wow I was weird I
almost felt like this sir Joe telling it
in the show I felt like the surge when I
was up there it's weird [ __ ] surge I
went through my body yeah and then when
I got offstage I got a phone call from
her telling me hey I can't do this
anymore I'm sorry I can't take it I love
you I just want to let you know crying
well like when I got offstage I'm like
why I look I'm like why she she knows
I'm working why would she call yep and
then I rushed home and but I think you
know like I think I felt that like when
I was onstage yeah something something
weird when I was in the middle of show
me why I was [ __ ] weird did you move
out after yeah I never went back
Wow I went back one time a year later I
couldn't walk back in that apartment Wow
yeah that's lucky I had family around
where I just you know I backed I
basically moved in my mom for like four
months
yeah that's [ __ ] heavy it was so then
I want to get home like I can't go back
to that place yeah how did she do it do
pills and oh yeah and booze you know
yeah yeah so at least it wasn't like a
craziness you know no no yeah
a buddy of mine not a buddy but a guy I
know his wife hung herself that's brutal
oh I know to find somebody it adds years
on to it when you find a person to Oh
because it's that yeah you know so
that's all we started and someone
hanging is really I mean one shot or
something like that is powerful blood so
[ __ ] spooky man I know so that's a
rough gig you know it's I've had some
dark times but I've it's so weird I've
never thought about killing myself
though you know you just and and and it
seems like a week later everything's
great you're like oh god you know it's
just life but some people it's in their
brain yeah cuz a lot of people don't
understand the pressure like somebody
could I don't know lose a good gig they
were opening as a comic they were gonna
headline the comedy works yeah and make
$2,000 that week like oh my god I need
it this is perfect then all of a sudden
their agent goes look somebody else is
going in there that weekend think I have
to move you back or they didn't get a
good report on you so then you know I
can't do the gig and they take that like
it's the worst thing in the world that
they want to end their life us if you
don't have depression issues that sucks
you're down you're bummed out but you
recover from it yeah it's not life or
death sometimes then they think that is
when they're in that hole is something
little - it could be anything that could
trigger it but it's always you know you
lose it yeah but you didn't really like
the job to begin with and that's that's
um off so it's real it's real I mean so
many America Americans suffer from it
you know what I mean it's like I mean I
get emails all the time from people and
they're like ah thank God for your
podcast I got a terrible job yeah a [ __ ]
commune I just love listening they're
not and and I'm like right on man you
know like and and it's always so easy to
say hey don't you know it ain't nothing
dude you know but that's like it's a you
know like you pills you're throwing
pills at it and then you get off those
and it gets you up and down and it's a
yo-yo out there you know the worst thing
you could say to somebody that is is
thinking about doing committing suicide
is don't worry about all your friends
you got so much to live for they don't
want to hear that that doesn't make
sense to no that doesn't make it makes
sense to someone that doesn't want to
kill themselves obviously right but
someone that does is in that that
desperation and that deep dark
depression that means nothing - that's
the worst thing you could say
so what did you do you wrote the one-man
show to kind of get it get it out of
your system because it was haunting you
um I I just thought I had a good story
to tell and how I recovered from it
that's a dark story because I know what
you you were around when I was in the
motorcycle crash and I still haven't
really figured out how to do that bit
without people just closing off right
away from a crash and this is even way
darker well it takes a while that's why
when it comes to your well like there's
you know uh you know it might not be it
might be in three months you might be
able to figure out a way but just sit on
and until it's ready it took me like you
know two years to actually perform it
after it happened where I started right
I just started writing you got slides
over while you're doing yeah yeah well
that's even heavier yeah you're seeing
her you know
yeah I got her slides and yeah but it
just took me it took me a while a ride
in there just to get the balls to go up
there and tell a story about what
happened that night
yeah how I recovered from it I read from
my diary because I was writing a diary
afterwards
Wow and I read from that and then
eventually ultimi the story is basically
we used to go see Kid Rock every year me
and my axe right she we should we both
like Kid Rock that was like Nicky he
played every year at this place right by
a house B and C yeah
you notice uh so we good every year I
was like okay so now like cut to like
four years later I don't know maybe I
guess it was two years later now maybe a
three or four twenty was so anyway mom
kid rocks coming around and my buddy
calls me up you know one of these Jersey
guys yeah yeah
he's like hey dude he goes like hey dude
yeah he goes I got tickets for Kid Rock
tomorrow I got free tickets we're gonna
tailgate in the park a lot yeah and I
got a bunch of hot chicks coming you
know that I know yeah you win I go I
don't know and he's like what I mean you
don't know
I go mean I mean my ex that was our
thing we always did together I'm I feel
I'm gonna feel weird going what outer
and he's like dude does did you hear I
got your beer and hot chicks I go I know
I know he goes like oh let me think
about it man I gotta sleep on it and I
remember him before you hung out he goes
to he goes check your pants for a [ __ ]
before you hung up on them I can relate
to that too
if you would have said any other gig you
would have been in like Judas Priest
earlier but it's Kid Rock your lady the
killed or so yeah yeah
and that's kind
weird cuz it's gonna fire up stuff and
you're there like you're not there gone
chicks all right right exactly it wasn't
like all good I'm gonna get laid yeah if
you have exactly if it was priests I'm
like I'm for anyone yeah so uh and then
it basically like that night like I was
tossing a turn and does do I go I don't
know and then she basically came to me
in a dream whether I was dreaming or not
I don't know but yeah she basically said
go to that she'll believe me you'll
trust me you'll you'll thank me later
Wow so I go to the show and that's where
I met my ex-wife I was one of those hot
chicks that chick [ __ ] your ex Byrnes
yeah I know and I don't know why I think
yeah exactly
because I want a bet I want to [ __ ] him
one of her friends like eight months
after she passed away so they always say
maybe she must have watch and it okay
[ __ ] like one of my friends know
that concert you gonna make somebody
special you're gonna meet a monster yeah
but you know like the I didn't go hey
I'm like [ __ ] off rad course no no but
uh you know whatever we're having drinks
when I were talking about it you know
should happen yeah yeah yeah she was hot
why don't we uh yeah I've been there
no but we also had this corny thing
where we said that we won't have sex
with if one of us dies we won't have sex
with anybody else until we get to heaven
I was one of those drunken nice like of
course yeah man and then all of a sudden
like hottest sucks oh you know I'm
hurting but I do want it you know I got
I got to feel good again yeah yeah and I
thought about it later oh my god she
can't see
man so I don't know if she's heavy dude
so I don't know if you sent me because
of that but anyway so I met but but you
know what ultimately my you know my
future wife that thing blow up but I got
an amazing son out of the whole deal so
you know even though that's the drama
whatever you know they'll be part two at
least I got a killer son out of it now
when you shot the thing did it
eventually start to get popular this
thing he only did about twenty times you
said when you shot it was it somewhere
where it was packed out you know I was
doing like 150 seat theater a small
place well yeah I did it at UH
the Roosevelt that room that Beacher's
Madhouse [ __ ] in there I did it there I
did it there one night I did it at the
Comedy Central stage
out here that's the only two times they
did it out here and a lot in New York
and a Little Theatre in New York right I
did a New Jersey so you know how long is
it it's about an hour and ten minutes
Wow yeah and when you're doing it
because my the way I always pictured
open to mind was did you see that Kurt
Cobain movie which one the one called a
montage of heck mm-hmm yeah is that
what's got all the animation in it and
no I didn't see that when I saw the
other one I always pictured mine where
where it's like you're sitting there's
like a screen and it shows and I come
onstage and throw some headphones on and
then you see behind me the screen of
like the kiss record dropping and and
then footage of the the dynasty tour and
you know the rim right full [ __ ]
blast to really get the old oh wow
to see how I'm hooked you know but it's
so elaborate did you did it get billed
bigger as you started doing it not
really I wanted to kind of keep it
simple I definitely needed a slide show
- yes showing pictures my transformation
from short hair to long hair I was
always the good friend because I was
socially awkward and what a bad mustache
- real grew mustache like 18 so we look
oldest we can get liquor yeah yeah we
have to show ID that's right we're on
this one I want to look older would you
ever go mustache now maybe I don't know
I I had it for a long time that looks
bad I showed the pictures where I have
the bad mustache you show and I all my
friends were in bands and they were
getting laid and they had long hair oh
yeah I like to become an [ __ ] stop
being a good friend grow you shut that
shave that bad mustache off grow your
hair long you'll get [ __ ] tell me that
story real quick before we go on about
your buddy your boss had short hair and
you met a couple chicks one night and
they wouldn't [ __ ] and then you said
throw a wig on you guys ran into the
chicks again it was my landscaping boss
I had long hair that [ __ ] is hilarious
this is a hundred percent true so I work
for this landscape Brian long hair he
had short hair with glass like a nerdy
look a dude with a mustache yeah so I
tell him all these stories because I was
Dee
Jane in a rock club this is like the
late 80s those banging chicks left and
right the girls used to act like guys
back then yeah they will [ __ ] you and
then the next night they would blow you
off yeah oh yeah sorry I lost your
number and they would be hooking up with
somebody else they didn't follow you
around and stalk you or anything so
Friday night there's nobody else around
I'll [ __ ] a minute so much the next
night you go hey oh yeah oh yeah do get
over it yeah yeah look I [ __ ] you last
week you're lucky you got in there just
move on cuz people don't believe me I'm
like I'm telling you they were just they
were acting like dudes yeah so I would
go into work in the morning and tell him
all these stories like honey was single
he's like holy [ __ ] he cuz you got to
hook me out one of these girls yeah said
it was these two girls that like did I
met at the rock club so let's go to
lunch so we're landscape and yes we show
up there at love we have lunch with them
and we're just talking oh my god we
should go out tonight and they wanted
girl goes look I'm sorry but I only like
guys with long hair and my boss is older
and he was all dinner man he was like
you know 30 I was like 20 and he's like
that's what does that but I'm a good guy
goes like I'm sorry but I only like guys
with long hair you have sure I'm sure
you're a nice guy but it's not doesn't
work for it's a Jersey chick stuff there
they were like resilient I forget
they'll like Brazilian chicks or
something like that so so like I go so I
go I tell him afterwards when I go look
let's go to the mall and get your get
your wig in a Halloween store I go put a
wig on I go I'm telling you I won't he
goes they won't even know it was you I
go tonight I'll tell him I got a record
producer friend because he lived in a
friggin nice a beautiful house in the
woods with kuzey in the back
I'll sell new your producer Metallica
yeah he produced Metallica record in
this your house in Jersey and we're
gonna go over there and he's got a
jacuzzi and we'll have drinks he's like
yeah but they just saw me at lunch egg
I'm telling you just so stupid so we
went to the mall we got a [ __ ] long
hair wig almost like a Howard Stern
weight but it was brown and he [ __ ]
put it on straight Britney Fox wig yeah
like yeah and we're not gonna and he
hated heavy metal like he's like into
like you know [ __ ] the band and oh
yeah like that what it would so if I
like I'm half in half right but he's so
he was in that we'd always argue like
why you listening so I show up at his
door he has to wig on yeah and he's like
hey how are you bring the Metallica
records I want to show them where we're
having my gas hole and I saw him in the
wig is like come on in girls come
with the but still with the mustache I
gotta go back in the car for a second I
went in a car and laugh like ten
straight minutes like oh I gotta get
this laugh out because I can't stop this
decision yeah they don't notice is the
same guy had a mean eight hours later
yeah next day I know we both both hooked
up with him that night oh man that I
remember I brought Master of Puppets
over and we had it on his on his record
player and he hated [ __ ] metallic
especially cranking notes on this verse
right here I told him to turn up the
bass yeah he said he was like Associate
Producer but they didn't put him on the
record he's showing a back look
Flemington I think oh whatever his name
he's a Galvez but they didn't put me on
here for some reason but I'm on the next
one [ __ ]
oh my god and we went to Z where they
keep that wig right yeah I don't know
what he did with it but I have a picture
of him somewhere I still have it of him
in the wig yeah oh my god write a story
I was soaked and we hooked up with both
of them that is so [ __ ] funny yeah
that's straight eighties right though
yeah without he's like which one you
like I go whatever one you like I don't
care whatever one likes you it doesn't
matter
oh my god no so this thing where did you
shoot it I shot it in New York oh cool
yeah the players theater no it was a
different place I forget the name it
actually venue because I did I shot it a
bunch of times it's there we camera
shoot okay yeah right on now how long is
this oh it's an hour and 10 minutes and
then you also get a CD with it right
yeah the DVD version as a DVD and a CD
inside or the digital download you can
get it's all my website jim Florentine
calm and you have you put the promo code
Florentine and you get the digital
download for five bucks yeah yeah
there's a DVD CD you can get to that you
know so in case people want you know an
actual copy this is cool you you and I
have been talking quite a bit lately of
like no one's no one's pounding on our
doors to do specials and stuff so it's
like this is the best time ever to just
do our own [ __ ] you know absolutely put
that out myself I'm like I'm not waiting
anymore I'm gonna shoot another one in a
couple months
yeah you know I'm just like and I got
still one sitting in the from the Jersey
theater yeah sitting on the shelf that
I'm [ __ ] you know that's been close to
being sold so I got you know
I really want to put out three specials
this year I know that's insane it's
great though but why not because I had
the other one I did a year ago
yeah this one was from two years ago and
this one's almost ready it's like 90%
ready this one so I'm like one of my
wait wait waiting time for so I'll just
get it out there put it out myself you
don't need a you know I'd love to be on
that flex and you never know sometimes
when you put something out a catch
they'll pick it up so we'll say yeah you
uh know how long you been doing comedy
since 91 92 Wow how many years is that
25 years almost 25 years
yeah yeah I love it man me too that's
the best how [ __ ] great is there
right I really feel like right now
comedy and rock are I mean I can tell
from the response of people from the
podcast and the in the shows man it is
aligning you know like like 80s dice and
Kinison and stuff absolutely I mean look
at all the guys that are doing Thea
doing uh you know Madison Square Garden
arenas yeah you know Aziz Russell Peters
Amy Schumer Bilborough
yeah louis c.k yeah you know just five
right off the bat I'm sure I'm missing
like three other ones
yes gardening you know they're doing a
garden it's unbelievable and you know
Louis did four nights there
filbert dated Amy Schumer's doing it in
June it's Aziz has done it Russell
Peters is you know biggest comic in the
world so it's amazing so it's a great
time for comedy it really is it is man
and you've been doing it since 91 which
is amazing because you've got like a I
mean it's so great to have a career
doing comedy you know my buddy Mike
Beach he's an actor
he's been acting always [ __ ] life he
just landed a movie on the Boston
bombings but you know he's on ER for
[ __ ] six years then he's on another
show for seven years but my point is it
happens to some people and it's like
you're blessed you know I was just
thinking about dice - cos dice was on
our Jimmy Fallon I did stand-up on it's
like he's still at 58 years old is still
selling you know I don't know whatever -
three
thousand five thousand seats having a
bass basically uh a resurgence in his
career with the acting totally and then
it's coming you know with the comedy
people coming back to see him he's got
the show on Showtime's got a show at
show Tommy hit vinyl on HBO and then he
did a [ __ ] Woody Allen yeah I know
where he stole the jazz I know he almost
was off for a supporting act they're so
believable he's been doing great and you
know and he took a lot of time off
everyone's like well dices not around
anybody want to raise his kids yeah
entourage is where he really came back
yeah you know the guy apparently from
what I hear the guy sees him in a coffee
bean and says hey man my boss who
created entourage loves you and he's oh
yeah yeah and he said yeah yeah you
should come meet him and next thing you
know he's in the next whole season and
it was a fantastic storyline the guy I
think that dice like called him out if
I'm not mistaken so put him on the phone
and call him right now yeah and he
called the guy right now and right there
and I need I just got on the phone when
I said well let me come in and agree for
something and the next day and always
reading for some what a great role him
and Johnny Drama are doing a cartoon of
the Johnny bananas or whatever it is
yeah oh my god he's it's uh it's it's
amazing to see him still around because
I'm fifty and you grew up with him also
and it's it's you know like that guy
could completely be long gone
name a dude from the 80s right now
that's working besides Seinfeld and you
know maybe a couple other dudes in a big
huge current level yeah I know there's
some guys that are still doing the clubs
and stuff gets don't make eleven but
luck I always when I get in lucky is you
set goals but I just said if I can make
a living at what I love doing I'm good
that's it man I remember when I was 36
years old I was still paying my bills
and change I would bring it down at a
local supermarket I don't know change
dang what where they take like 18 cents
on the dollar those [ __ ]
I just did star yeah [ __ ] what a
bastards I know cuz I'm like I'm not
rolling this [ __ ] I I know [ __ ] it man
rolling quick
I had a Alhambra the big big [ __ ]
water bottle yeah full took me and my
buddy two guys to pick it up and I
periscoped it and it took a half
are pouring in there and had 400
something bucks for ya what a score
yeah but that's what I did I saw I
remember I like third I think I was 36
and I was paying changed I'm like [ __ ]
man something my friends were all living
in houses got a family with two kids
yeah big house I'm in a little shitty
apartment you know and uh and then I
want to blend that a commercial it was
it it was a Budweiser commercial just
introducing Bud Light this is probably
98 99 Wow there were just introduced in
Bud Light over in England it was a
series of like 4 commercials and it was
it was a one lump a of like 17 grand Wow
and I'm like holy [ __ ] and I was like -
I was wobbly like 30,000 and credit card
debt yeah I was barely making my bills I
was painting a change I had good credit
so I was just putting [ __ ] on credit
cards if I needed it yeah that's my car
whenever that good credit man yeah
you're gold so I was using three
different cards I was switching at six
months no interest here moving round
yeah I got that 17 grand in my pocket
and then I got one like a month after
that another commercial Wow for like you
know eight grand what was that for
that was for Samuel Adams and I was as
opposed to another beer commercial yeah
I'm gonna eight grand
yeah even if they do is I already cashed
a check and I took all that money I put
a right to my credit card to pretty much
paid off my credit cards in one last
song that's what I did with the cube
film so I got a big big amount of money
and then I realized on that film that I
was gonna start doing comedy and just
killed a credit card and then put the
rest of the bank and said I'll live on
$20 a day and at two years of doing
comedy I was two solid years in of every
day and then I got a job and didn't tell
anyone selling motorcycles cuz I didn't
want the headlines to go I he's got a
job he can't go on the road apps I
didn't tell anybody [ __ ] and I was I was
getting up every morning 8:00 work all
day go I'm sleep for an hour then go out
all [ __ ] night yeah no you have to do
that man you have you gotta go he's got
a day job so don't mean you let me give
it to a guy that doesn't have a day job
that really needs it so yeah yeah which
is crazy to think because it's like I
really needed it because that's why I
got a [ __ ] job you know
that's how rock-bottom he are you're
like uh-oh I got to get a job and as if
people are listening to say everyone
works [ __ ] but when you're
trying to get somewhere in comedy a job
will really [ __ ] you up your well and
you don't like to think about comedy or
in show business you don't know if
you're gonna make it you have no idea
there's no you're not putting money away
in a pension or 401k you know what I'm
you know you know anything so yeah he's
you know you're struggling you're barely
making any money so you not even putting
any money for social security you know
if you're making 50 I was making you
know between like 10 and 20 grand for
the first like nine years I made 17
grand I just saw the taxes so that's all
I'm a I was making for a long time and
then I got a big bump but once I got
that bump with those commercials then I
got audited by the IRS so I remember
going in they go wait how could you go
from 17,000 for the last nine years to
65,000 Robert was I'm like well I got
these commercials like I just want to
know how did you live yeah and you know
this money for nine years ago I didn't
care I go I bought a Toyota Tercel yeah
and I just got 40 miles to a gallon and
I would just go I Drive to Connecticut
three hours away for $25 on a Tuesday
night I didn't care act's I just wanted
to make it I was living my parents or I
was playing you know $280 a month in
rent it was me Jim Norton my ex
girlfriend living together the Brent was
eight hundred a month Wow splitting it
three ways and we living right outside
of New York City in a [ __ ]
Wow and I had a Turner to sell I got 40
miles to a gallon of 50 bucks I'll take
it
75 art I'll take it 100 miles for the
weekend no problem yeah and that's how
you know I didn't care because I was
like you know I stopped basically
working three years in this doing
stand-up because I was working like five
nights a week I was making twenty five
bucks 50 or whatever but I was getting
by yep
yeah idle living at home for a while
then I moved in with no Arden and an act
so I think it's the craziest thing not
for you but for like me is eventually
things start happening in your rowing
and you go oh I'm gonna leave this job
and then there's no stability all of a
sudden you're like well I call it holes
in the calendar
I start looking I'm like well I don't
have [ __ ] all of like May right now like
right now yeah I look at that and I go
holy [ __ ] and and I'm lucky I can do
eBay like I just eBay people [ __ ] and
and thank God can kind of sir
five from going in and out on eBay and
stuff but man those holes are scary you
know what are you doing on eBay what
well like I'll have somebody like right
now I got a couple bikes I'm selling for
guys that this is okay there's so many
people that don't add a work computer
still is right so you'll do it for them
right okay yeah or they're like a
celebrity and they don't want people at
their house that kind of stuff I'll sell
their automobiles I'm sure all right and
and and so anything to keep the eye on
the prize you know prize is not fame or
money prize is doing comedy
yeah and that's [ __ ] amazing to me
that like Here I am six years in and I'm
doing comedy you know ya know it's new
years old I know it's not late I started
at like 25 and I thought that was late
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] but that's what I
finally realized what I wanted to do
yeah and once I did it I'm like this is
it I don't give a [ __ ] now your let's
see your you've been out on first of all
I don't think I had you on since you
were on Louie
have I no that was one of my favorite
episode a couple days ago I had a drea
I'm from sapanta Sopranos and I told her
the four greatest shows are all in the
family
Sopranos Breaking Bad and Louie those
are this for me and then f is for family
now because I just love how gangster it
is but those are the shows for me over
the you know 40 years of my 50 years of
my life that have massive impact and you
were on one of the greatest episodes of
Louie man and it's [ __ ] phenomenal
yeah that was the last episode of last
season let's talk about this you you see
him and he says I've got something for
you and that's like two years ago it was
a crazy story so I'm working on that
metal show yeah and my manager is
friends with the woman that cast
Californication right they're good
friends but we're out here I'm we're
filming that metal show right right and
my manager says hey you know the creator
Tom capitis of California he's a huge
metal head if you watch the shoulders
always Slayer Marilyn Manson reference
he was always you know rock eyes on he
goes maybe I could set up a meeting I'm
sure he knows you from that metal
he has all that [ __ ] in the show I know
to the casting director I gotta go out I
got a day off on Wednesday yeah next day
and almost sitting in his office we sat
there for three hours just talking metal
I felt like I was in my room there was
Slayer posters [ __ ] yeah Black
Sabbath [ __ ] coffee books and [ __ ]
and then finally he's like you want to
be on the show I'm like yeah he goes uh
I goes what do you want to do I go I'll
do anything and he calls me two weeks
later you want to play a pimp I go yeah
it goes right where Metallica shirt by a
pimp I don't want you to play a
stereotypical Pam so I get that role so
I'm on the set for like four days now
Pam Alden or yeah yeah yeah so she's on
this he plays his wife on Louie and
lucky Louie
yeah it's white but it's girlfriend Ron
Louie right so she's on Californication
I love her by the way it's great so
after the first day the next day I see
on a set she goes oh my god I was
telling Louis last night how funny you
are
and he's like and he and he told me goes
I got a great idea for Jim for my show
yeah I'm gonna write Jim in an episode
now he knew you he know me yeah he knows
me from fantasy yeah yeah yeah we
weren't good close friends we I didn't
have his number or anything like that
but we all know what's going on you know
and when he had kids I'd always talked
on when I had my first kid we sit down
at the comedy store anyway so he goes I
got a great I'm gonna write him in an
episode I'm like wow that's really cool
I tell my manners like that's amazing
don't hear nothing for two years two
years go by last January my marriage
like hey we got an offer for you to do
Louis show he wants to know if you want
to do the episode he wrote it just for
you or I'm like what is it he goes I
don't know but he wants I go he goes we
want you to come in New York and read it
because I had to stand there in front of
the producer and read it because he
didn't want the [ __ ] out there in case
I've stolen the script yeah so I go I go
I don't even give sure what it is I'm in
he goes we want you to read it first to
make sure you like the role I go in I
read the script I'm like I'm in yeah and
basically what he did is went to hear my
name as a seat does a prank call I have
where I tell a guy he's trying to sell
me some some toilet thing that I'd have
to take an upper Decker because there's
so much [ __ ] in my balls
yeah and it's also I did it on a
hidden-camera DVD where I took a [ __ ] in
the top of a toilet tank
that's called an upper Decker I called
the front desk and a cheapo telling us
that if something's wrong with this
toilet it won't because every time you
flush the toilet when you take an upper
deck a little piece of [ __ ] go into the
bottom of the bowl
for the day yeah we've been doing that
since kid for years it must be a jersey
thing so the guy takes the lid off
eventually cuz what the hell's going on
he sees it to [ __ ] in the top of it
throws me out of the hotel yeah
so Louis yeah yeah yeah he's [ __ ] phew
yeah he said his mine and I put that on
a hidden camera thing that I did and
then I did it in a prank call though we
always remembered that [ __ ] upper
Decker is so funny so he writes upper
Decker where I die from taking an upper
Decker in the episode I guess the
episode obviously was another comic
openin forum and he's you know it scene
after condo in it and and the thing is
when I read that I'm like this is
perfect cuz I know how to play this guy
I've been working with this guy in the
road for the last 15 years yeah
sharing a condo what them are just you
know doing gig basically playing the
annoying feature down the road that the
now guys that are big they bring their
own feature but when you're a medium guy
you show up a Cubs and you work with
whoever's there and it could be the
dirtiest comic it could be a guy that's
crushing or a guy that's terrible all
kinds of dynamics or guy that just does
coke and booze and everything so your
character is amazing cuz you're like a
partier and you're like a kind of a
comic that's like yeah let's do it and
Louie's like Louie yeah and we also back
in a day you know to still have them
sometimes you share a condo ders yeah
the comedy club buys a condo near to
near the club and all the comedians have
to stay at the condo so now you live in
with a guy for five days that you don't
even know yeah just [ __ ] weird which
is great to be around all day and [ __ ]
like that and you're in your room and
he's out in the living room watching TV
and then psych so I always I always work
with that annoying guy I would just want
to start drinking at noon and yeah
[ __ ] didn't give a [ __ ] about comedy
or anything I was always the guy to hit
in my room god this [ __ ] guy's
annoying well they treat the road like
just like to party yeah man like I can't
wait to touch those are the dudes that
are already drinking at the at the
airport yeah what are you doing I know
I've always said never drink before I go
on I might have a couple afterwards
right yeah I'm never drinking at noon
and I guess I gotta show the show is the
most important thing for me so that was
the episode we're sharing a hotel and
then we have the gig and I'm blowing
them off to stage some dirty and
disgusting and just telling these bad
jokes
yeah he's getting mad and then we have a
big fight at the end and then we make my
favorite part is where he's just bombing
the whole weekend and the owner switches
you guys and I've heard people say that
that's actually happened yeah where the
yeah and there's a great scene where
Louise he's like we're gonna have such
and such headline and Louie ghost I get
paid the same he goes yeah I don't give
a [ __ ] cause you should yeah cuz
basically it's like a band like the
opening bands blowing the headliner off
the stage
it's G&R in the cult yeah yeah so we've
got to switch the order so they switch
the order and then you know I'm going on
after him but no it was great and then
then we had the big fight over it
because I don't care I'm like one of
these guys like hey man we're just
telling jokes yeah it's a big deal man
stop taking everything so serious I
don't know if you can tell this story
you told it to me off the mics but while
you're shooting that there's a scene
that you don't get and you need to shoot
it like a week later but you have a
weekend book that you can't cancel
because you had canceled on these people
before and you totally like look I can't
do it and Louie was like how do I fix
this so can you tell that's yeah
absolutely yes yeah unbelievable and it
makes me love you even more it was
amazing did the scene be if you didn't
see the episode if you saw it we
basically we become friends and we start
drinking and we went up trash in a condo
yeah and would you they never showed
that they cut all that so we were
[ __ ] breaking the walls crashing
their windows doing all the [ __ ] yeah
and um I guess did not last night we
were supposed to film it he does that
wasn't right
for some reasons that I had to cancel a
cancel last night they go look we got to
film this next Thursday and I go I can't
do it next Thursday goes that's the only
day we could do it the last day of
shooting I go I have to be at this
comedy club in Syracuse and I can't
cancel again I start on Thursday I
already cancelled a month ago I was
doing something else okay so I cannot
can't there's no way but he needed me
for the scene obviously I said I want to
do this so I go just tell Louie you know
because I'm talking to a producer and
then Louis comes in Maitreya goes
alright what can I do to make this work
is that's the only day we could shoot
his next Thursday I go I gotta be in
Syracuse I got this gig I cancelled he
goes all right he goes how about you
tell them this oh you
show up Thursday go cuz I gotta be in
the mood for Friday morning radios have
to be answer he goes oh I'll come with
you on Friday and I'll do the two shows
with you they can advertise my name and
everything like that and then and
everyone will come to the club it'll be
packed in the club the radio you know to
do the radio or anything that can
advertise the Louie CK is coming to do
Stu sure because I got new material I
want to work on anyway I'll come up
there on Friday night and just do the
two shows with you know my holy [ __ ] so
I tell it owner like all right no
problem
amazing about that is not only do you
get to do movies TV show but now you get
to open form yeah we're gonna hop on a
plane like first thing in the morning or
something and fly up there he's gonna do
the two shows [ __ ] so cool so I said
I said they go okay no problem we'll let
you in out of it you know getting up
here on a Thursday night and then and
then a couple days later like it's Louie
showing up as Louie showing up and then
eventually like he couldn't show up oh
he didn't sell he didn't show because he
didn't we actually you know what
happened was as soon as I said I said
okay we need him up here so as soon as I
was done filming yeah they said they
Louie sent me a pound car huh like a
limo and drove me from New York City to
Syracuse New York which is like five
hours Wow and I get up there like 5:00
in the morning how to go on the radio
like 600 sent a car to get me up there
right from the set Wow
and it was no one in a [ __ ] blizzard
and stuff so but Louie's like I'd love
to but I can't make it but he actually
offered that he goes well I have to just
to make sure you do this that would've
been insane that's [ __ ] cool man i
tell my god Lily if you do that I go
you're going I'm going on before you
yeah yeah [ __ ] no way if I kill I don't
give a [ __ ] if it's brand new with you
you're brand new material is a hundred
times better than my [ __ ] that I've been
doing for two years and it's just people
also so fired up yeah yeah I know so it
was such a nice gesture by him to I'm
not that guy what a what a what a great
show to be on because Louie the actual
show man there's a episode the three
episodes where he's going to get the
Late Show
possibly and I think it could be some of
the best TV I've ever seen it's got
David Lynch
playing the guy teaching him how to do a
mate show yeah and in its three-part
episode
and then at the end like Chris Rock gets
it or whatever but uh or Seinfeld but
it's just incredible the show and it's a
bummer it's gone but he's got the new
one now Horace and Pete which is cool no
he's still doing a show he hasn't shot
any yeah okay well he hate that season
just ended it uh right well last June
yeah so we'll see ya know when he's
supposed to do it again in the fall
oh let's do another season no he's he's
on he's doing another shifts hope for me
still yeah you know I died at the end so
I but you know you never know yeah I was
like ah too bad you can't come back you
never know Louis does weird [ __ ] oh I've
seen him he's used different guys yeah
four he'll bring a guy in he'll play one
part in a month a year later he'll bring
the guy in and play another part I love
that yeah you know baby and I actually
got submitted for an Emmy for that role
Wow for a best guest star you know on a
TV show I didn't get nominated but I
think that I was submitted for was
insane yeah greatest yeah I believe so
it's great it's how my acting real helps
me get out of your acting gigs and yeah
you also did the Amy Schumer film yeah
which is great I mean that film was
humongous
you got any TV going on now uh no I
don't have anything right now going on
that metal show that's gone but you guys
are trying to pitch it other places and
this is a boring question because people
ask you over and over I don't care I see
it wherever we go hey what's going on
with that metal show if that many people
count it you know kid what it was I know
my man yeah I know we'd be a [ __ ]
beatin American Idol on the radio
whatever pop you know yeah we're
basically the company Viacom [ __ ] the
bed yeah oh and make a corporate you
know corporate decision came in and made
major cuts that it cut a bunch of [ __ ]
they own like six different networks
yeah vh1 MTV Comedy Central Nickelodeon
and you know one of our shows didn't
make the cut our show didn't make the
cut alone a ton others so but they said
go out and go sell somewhere else you
guys are black that's the name and
everything yeah so a lot of times I just
go [ __ ] you too bad well yeah Mandy not
getting and that's it so you know we got
agents out there shop but I'd say it's
probably
35% chance of Lana's somewhere else yeah
I never you know and then we got other
avenues we could do we could always do
maybe all nine thing if we have to or
something so we'll say yeah it's not
dead but it you know it's not you know
it's not it's I don't know I'd say yeah
probably about a 3035 percent chance
yeah you know what if not we did it for
7c we're on for seven years yeah it's
insane hundred forty episodes I'll take
that and are those episodes available on
Netflix or anything no no nothing right
now this is on vh1 classic got yeah they
just showed up repeats I've never even
watched vh1 since it I only watched it
to watch you guys that never what I
don't even well I don't even got a TV no
but nobody does Yeah right but uh yeah
so we'll see what happens
yeah you know when I got a million other
things going on it's great because we
film that basically in two weeks we'd
knock out like 12 episodes of 14
episodes and we're done for the year
which is great so it's not a lot of time
out of that right right yeah so we'll
see what happens it's it's crazy that
they got rid of the show because you
shot it in LA forever and you just come
out and you'd shoot all of them in one
week and then they built that full set
free in New York and have you do it
weekly they put all that money into the
set it's mind-boggling I don't know I
don't know what's going on I don't you
know yeah you know meanwhile you could
knock out a whole season if you do one
of these festivals like a rock on the
range or twenty days three day metal
festival so great you could set on the
tent in the tent or you could just set
her bus or you could set out like almost
like when the NFL does it we're outside
the stadium oh yeah in the parking lot
out there with the fans in the
background like rainy day or something
like that it doesn't matter where we
shoot it nope so you know no money at
all it's just all about the guest
exactly when they're all the bands are
right there so you're not even paying
for them to come in to do the show put
them up in a hotel or any that [ __ ] so
who knows what are your I don't think
I've seen you since the Brian Johnson
thing but Wow right it's unbelievable I
talk about it every [ __ ] episode
because I don't think people realize
obviously this is one of the biggest
bands in the world to me I got bonds got
tattooed on me I worship the band and
and I've seen him three times this year
you know and it's just like wow
I mean that really knocked the wind out
of me like what for real you know like
Brian's out you saw mr. Issa it was
great believable yeah I was going into
Madison Square Garden was real sweet
this past Monday yeah um still got that
ticket no I didn't have a ticket yet but
I was going yeah cuz it might be Axl
well what I'm hearing is if it if they
do two guest singers for the 10 or 11
shows will be a few different guys yeah
so Axl will do you know maybe four or
five songs you know accent was doing a
whole lot of Rosie yeah of course in his
Guns N'Roses version kill off time to
kill in it so he could do to Bon Scott
stuff no problem
yep you know what I mean so you know I I
don't know you know but you know but
then again when when when Bon Scott died
you know Ozzy you know auditioned for
ac/dc well yeah yeah you know what it
was just like they both knew he wasn't
gonna get it but like my come on in what
trial ever did I ever do it so maybe you
know Axl went in there is like hey I
just wanna have some fun jamming you
guys cuz that's like one Axl's favorite
bands of all time yeah you can just say
did that Tyler went down for Zeppelin
right Tyler what's that plan and all
those guys and Sammy Hagar you know yeah
like that so I don't know I don't know
what's going on um it just seems like
you know angles wants to do with that
sort of here to rumor Angus still wants
to do a seed he's even the next 10 years
yep Brian Johnson 68 Angus is 61 this is
a good way to get Brian Johnson added a
band to get a new guy because you can't
just say we're getting rid of Brian
Johnson yeah because there's the fans so
they jump on the medical excuse no
matter we love Timmy gave us a great but
you know steering's or what are we gonna
do you know so it seems like I don't
know but now everyone's quiet you know
that camp is always quiet it's totally
quiet I'm gonna hear their audition or
other singers so I know Brian hasn't
even talked I know I wonder if there's
some kind of contractual thought sure
I'm sure like oh yeah absolutely
because you know you'd be right out
there you know yeah without a doubt I
mean there's stuff go get out there was
secondhand through yeah through Jim
Breuer just talking to him so I don't
know man it just said if that's if
that's the case they should at least let
him do what they should do is just you
know luck Brian you know
you know cuz they were only doing like
two shows a week right 68 years old is
stuff on them so let Brian do the last
10 11 shows and go look I'm gonna retire
after this [ __ ] move on again my
blessing let them we're gonna know the
singer yeah I could do that you know so
that would be the best way to do it
that's what I say and also I say change
it to Angus Young and friends after
everyone would go have the same dudes
and then different singers all the time
like you know theater runs doesn't have
to be like a big theaters like a you
know this run we've got Axl and the next
run we've got you know Steven Tyler or
whatever but you know what you know what
the thing is that that's a brand name
agency pangas owns that obviously with
Malcolm forget it so that and you know
what the thing is I got a kid in three
years from now if Angus is playing with
some tribute guy they used to be an
ac/dc band somewhere and he sounds
amazing
Elroy you mean yeah yeah
he's I'm gonna go see him do you know
that singer yeah I know my god maybe I
don't see if we get backstage it's so
funny because I I look at it it's like
people go hey man would you do that if
you got it I was like man it's [ __ ]
hard like I went in sang an hour and a
half at the birthday party and you know
if you're singing twice three times a
week and that volume is on a hundred and
man that [ __ ] is like you're you're
spent at least I mean it you know they
rather did they usually do four or five
shows a week it's so crazy at that at 58
60 and said I was 50 when I did and I
was like cut this [ __ ] is loud imagine
cannons and anguses action all that [ __ ]
you're like get me out
you know No so um but you know like like
I said I would go see them like three
years my son I want to see ac/dc yeah
you know the younger generation doesn't
care and it's like I don't still you
know even though it's Angus the guy
sounds like Bond and Brian so what am I
gonna do oh yeah Stone the band and so
it's crazy to think about right I know
but they know that you know these bands
know if there's like two or three guys
originals then get away with it
so yeah yeah totally who who you
listening to right now I don't you know
it hasn't been anything really that
great that I've been listening to
anything
yeah I've really been searching out the
metal shows been off for almost a year
now
yeah so I'm usually in that mode where
I'm always trying to find new bands so
but I've really been into it I've been
just busy with other [ __ ] so I really
haven't like I did new Megadeath and
anthrax I god I've listened to it a
couple times I haven't really not that I
don't like it I just haven't had time to
really just dig into it yeah yeah I hear
you I hear I hear a lot of stuff on XM
you know when I'm like in a rental car
whatever and then I'll be like oh yeah
there's the new such-and-such or
whatever but I mean you know I got a
wall of records over there I'm pretty
much good right now yeah no I was just
lost no other plasmatic Sandip all right
oh yeah I was listen to beyond the
valley of 1984 we had like almost like a
punk metal record I love dope that Todd
is their masterpiece oh man oh that's a
great metal record but that should
master plan and sex junkie it's great I
feel like that's right for Ivan listen
out in the wild Mike's is so [ __ ]
good I saw the guy solo John what was
his name along the Mohawk yeah John
yes Laura whatever song Claude Van Damme
crazy I saw that guy solo really yeah
and he had the songs along the Mohawk or
whatever he had kind of a semi hit on
that record I saw him at like the stone
or something but wow what what a radical
that band that was you know I wish one
deal was still around man because they
would be popular like there weren't you
know yeah it was the originator doing
that [ __ ] you can't start blowing up
cars and [ __ ] on stage I know and those
old TV shows all that [ __ ] and chainsaws
and you know the electrical tape
underneath I saw I remember front row
tear open from Motorhead yeah and that
was her solo band Wendy Williams I did
the solo thing it's my life and all that
[ __ ] and I was in the front row as a kid
she's in our underwear and [ __ ] just
electrical tape on her nipples yeah
chainsaw and I'm 17 years old I'm like a
home like this the hottest chick average
it does big fake tits
oh yeah I was always a plasmatic I got
to see him a couple times and when do
solo so that's what I was just listening
to when I see you have a Motorhead no
sleep the Hammersmith
yeah I just got that it's the hundred
and eighty milligram reassured sounds
so good man you know they put a you know
extra you know sleep to Hammersmith like
a whole other bite the bullet and a
bunch all the songs that didn't make
these I got that on iTunes I love that
man alright alright it's like half the
whole show you know this is so short
because it's one vinyl yeah you know and
I'm kind of surprised that how many
songs they fit onto that vinyl you know
but wow this record sounds great man I
think it's the the Motorhead record that
you need you know like if you're out
there like all the live records to me
are great if you want blood no sleep the
bootleg Aerosmith live bootleg I was
rocking a couple days ago all of them
are great you know yeah the live records
you know kiss alive 1 & 2 those are the
ones Peter Frampton Cheap Trick Budokan
I think I think the theory was that they
could have captured a great sound in the
70s with some of that stuff like the
Nugent double live gonzo unleash nice
yeah you know the music just pop the
ones once it was live stranges a night
UFO all the arrangements live and
dangerous than lizzy those records are
just [ __ ] classics and Frampton Comes
Alive was another one that's the big one
yeah do you feel like I do 12-minute
version you know he you know he's
touring with a bad company right no it's
them and Skynyrd oh they're Skynyrd a
bad company who are they with bad
company and someone else yeah it's
another good Joe Walsh yeah that's
that's gonna be great yeah that's gonna
be good to like old dudes on the couch
oh that's gonna be great CDs guys I
never saw a bad company I never saw Joe
Walsh
yeah I saw Frampton about a year ago for
the first time but I like I saw the who
about a month ago for how was that they
were great right it's great Starkey whoo
I never saw before and I said you know
what I might as well go see Emma does
not Bob Seger's another one I want to
see ya before you know who knows you
know look we lost basically pretty much
ac/dc and Motorhead yeah in the metal
community in two months it's crazy and
we lost Merle Haggard today who's a huge
point even now he don't died today while
you were flying here
yeah you know last week you canceled
some dates double pneumonia and boom he
dies today one of the biggest country
stars of all time in our somebody bands
covered his stuff but people I say 2016
took out way more rock stars than any
drugs ever you know sure why I mean you
know Scott Weiland was right before 2006
yeah it's like I don't it start at
filthy animal till I was you know the
drummer Motorhead yep the classic
Motorhead he was a month he died a month
before or Lemmy yeah you and I went to
Lemmy's birthday party yeah and then
boom he was gone a few weeks later it
was just insoluble and what a great
night that was you know it's just like
wow this is so much so much fun
everybody was celebrating and then gone
I was glad I went because it was you
know I know you almost didn't go yeah
good night a change flights and do all
the [ __ ] I'm like I gotta get out there
it's this birthday party oh man so we
had a great night that night we all went
to the rainbow oh yeah we ate was there
yeah it was great Russell Peters the
elusive Norton he's not somebody out I
know yeah yeah I know he doesn't make
appearances okay so this is out now I'm
your Savior I'm your Savior to just set
if you buy the DVD get a CD also and and
you and you can get it on your website
jim Florentine common you got a digital
download it's five bucks if you put
promo code Florentine in Y and then or
you want the DVD CD all the [ __ ] will be
shipped out and all that stuff - that's
cool man it's a one-man show - some good
storytelling it's funny it's tragic it's
a little bit everything yeah I can't
wait to watch it because I've seen some
one-man shows I wanted to see Scott
Ian's I didn't get to see it right but
of course Rollins is being my all-time
favorite you go see him he calls it
spoken word but it's it's just two three
hours of stories and you're just you
can't believe how great they are
and it's an interesting format and I
really like it and also like Ari Shaffir
show right now this is not happening
yeah it's you know I'm working on a
couple stories hopefully one day get on
that but it's fun it's a different
dynamic
and there's no much so much pressure to
get laughs but it's fun to find some
laughs in there without a doubt it was
it was weird for me because you know I'm
going into theater and I'm used again
laughs yeah someone told me to go look
if no one's laughing if they're quiet
that means to listening just remember
that when you're doing it you don't
don't you don't to be a stand-up comic
and go for a laugh all the time yeah
because you start to you start to freak
a little bit right no come on I'm like
I'm on two minutes and I'm get a laugh
yet I'm trying to set up this story it
was weird for me so it took me a while I
really learned that but once I did I was
fearless about just the last will come
yeah just let it come so that was always
that was a big obstacle overcome you're
gonna do another like a storyteller or
one-man show style thing later you think
yeah braaap probably yeah yeah well be
more of a stand-up thing this was no
microphone in a theatre you know no
microphone you know my family yeah yeah
yeah oh wow yeah no mic Wow
yeah that's how I wanted to do it yeah
that's great but the next one won't be
with a mic that's cool and the next
one's basically about this new woman
that dirted you're right yeah you're
special should be called woman number
two
oh yeah 140 you know but look ultimate
you gotta look at it like maybe it's my
fault I'm the one picking them so I can
just blame it on everybody else yeah you
know I so you know I'll be very picky
I'll be very choosy about the next one
that's awesome man so jim Florentine
knows your Twitter and your Instagram
you got an Instagram
yeah it's jim Florentine I also I just
started a website called awful Facebook
post com oh cool where I just rip apart
people's Facebook posts I'm like a
newscaster behind a desk oh yeah what a
suit and tie on and I put a little
Facebook post up like in the background
on a green screen
oh that's tell you know whatever
somebody's you know mother nature go
home we don't like your weather and I
just you know like do just know mother
nature is not following you on facebook
you know what I mean that you have to
follow you to see this I looked at your
friends there's no money there's no
mother nature where's where's home for
mother nature tell me you know she'll
like that so I do it on my podcast so
I'm doing as a whole series I got awful
Facebook post calm and I post a few up
each week well that's great yeah so I
don't always see what happens it's
I shooted my friends basement it's fun
to do yeah people seem to enjoy
everyone's pretty much annoyed with
Facebook you know use it for the right
reasons yeah but everybody else is on
there looking for attention I'm on the
way to the hospital and then everyone
has to go for what are you okay you're
gonna be okay you know
they don't tell you why so you just want
everybody you know it's it's sad I hate
Facebook it's so bad you know I hate it
I just think it's such a bad format you
know what I mean they change it all the
time and I never had one there's a fan
page but it's just [ __ ] insane how
bad it is the layout and the look of it
and I can't believe it ever got popular
like myspace looks so good yeah I don't
know what happened you know it started
off as family you know they you call
pictures oh yeah you know what I mean
your your family in Seattle you don't
see them so you send people your picture
on facebook but then it turned into
everybody on they're going on there now
you know a lot of a lot of kids are
either on Twitter or snapchat about it
they're even leaving Twitter now at a
younger generation yeah snapchats a new
thing it's snapchat I can't stand either
I don't even get involved in that oh
it's so horrible because it's clunky and
there's there's no feed to look at and
try off it's a bat I can't believe that
thing's getting popular cuz it's like so
bad I love Instagram because I love
photos rights photos yeah which is good
a lot of people go on Instagram to you
know the thing with Facebook is this is
so much I like to go Twitter because I
can follow CNN which I want to know
what's the new ESPN I'm a big sport for
riding I like to sanfur to go giant so I
follow them but I do yeah yeah Wow yeah
today I know I didn't even know yeah we
lost today three to four all right well
you know it was a away game they always
lose that that one on the road no great
so I and I follow all my sports teams on
yes somebody need just need news I'll
fall blabbermouth.net which is the heavy
metal source so you know I just go right
on there see if anything's going on
instead of checking for different sites
so for me Twitter works Facebook half
the stories are fake yeah and then it's
just you know [ __ ] goofy videos
clunky videos where you can't scroll
down everything moves slow because
there's so much [ __ ] on are popping up
all over the place the page looks
Horrible's people sent me a science
enemy
sign me up for groups all now in these
groups teenage mothers against [ __ ]
you know bullies all my [ __ ] my
anyone could just put you in a group I'm
now I'm in a [ __ ] group jim
Florentine the teenage mother yeah I
know how my name is grew up you're
inviting me to a [ __ ] barbecue in
Idaho oh I'm not coming oh yeah yeah I
think the only thing I hate more than
that is group text shoot yourself no
that's brutal so that is okay I'll be
there I will too okay oh just boo-boo I
know boo all day and weeks later how was
it yeah oh who is Dez oh who is this
lost my phone new numbers Oh eat a dick
just so you don't know who it is
yeah yeah why do people still use that
one you know hey a new phone broke
screen who is this you know I always
when they say that I go your mom [ __ ]
mom let's get some sushi yeah let's do
it man go up to Phil Sissons place is it
his place yeah nice yeah it's cool it
ran called road shot in the dark
yeah he did Manny son loves that song he
wrote a bunch of songs on that Vince
Neil so a record yeah oh yeah yep yeah
had him on the podcast great dude cool
yeah I never met him before
all right cool I'm glad you're in town
you're in town for the weekend or
whatever we're gonna go see Guns & Roses
and I will talk about it on Monday
beautiful all right there he is right
there jim Florentine make sure you get
his news one-man special here I'm your
Savior and go to his website and check
out all the stuff thanks guys see ya
you